as far as you're concerned you're not in
the band because of Stevie that was what
I was told by Irving that she gave them
an ultimatum either Lindsay goes or I go
no and it would be like something as
absurd as Mick Jagger saying either
Keith goes or I go you know I well I
guess we need the singer yeah you know
so did you have any knowledge of how the
decision process went down with the band
none really no I mean I would love to I
did reach out I even wanted to go over
to Hawaii to see Mick or because Stevie
was vacationing over in Maui and wanted
to go over there and sit with him and
and and try to get through this but
there were there was clearly some other
agenda going on you know so I I don't
know what that process was mm-hmm maybe
never will
how would you describe your relationship
with Stevie I know it's at a lot of
different phases
my relationship with Stevie is
fragmented you know I think there's
still a lot of love there but you know
you have to begin with the fact that in
order to get through those early days it
was kind of an exercise in
compartmentalization for everyone
emotionally yeah and for me in
particular I mean I was not the one
doing the leaving she left me but there
was never really any chance to get
anything like closure because that takes
a perhaps some some distance and so that
that kind of you know is is how we got
along and I think you know you cut to 20
30 years later and that leads to a kind
of a fragmented relationship I think you
know sometimes she might find it
difficult that I was lucky enough to
find my soul mate late in life and got
married and had my first child when I
was 48 and have three beautiful children
and that was something she never did you
know she basically is living her
professional life and so maybe I I don't
know if that plays into it or not
yeah I honestly don't know
sounds like you've asked yourself a lot
of questions in the last year well you
know you try to understand it and beyond
a certain point you just have to accept
it in a way this is just another blip on
the radar you know you know pretty big
blip though pretty big blip and again as
I say I I'm not particularly
disappointed not to be out on the road
doing another Fleetwood Mac tour right
now doing all those hits what I am
disappointed in is that we built this
beautiful legacy that was about rising
above all of this kind of stuff I feel
that that legacy in what the band is
doing now is being somewhat dishonored
and that does bother me do you think
there's any chance you could play with
Fleetwood Mac again oh sure I mean I I
you know again I'm not assuming anything
at all but nothing would make me happier
than to if we were gonna do something
like a farewell tour so maybe they'll
get this out of their system and maybe
they'll realize that this wasn't really
the right thing and and if you're asking
me what would I be open yes of course
I would say yeah let's do it mm-hmm
absolutely